[musique]
l'ennemi ne se voit pas passera pas comme hier
un éclaireur a été littéralement découvert
OTAN
l'accompagnait étaient travail
voltage 4 heures on a travaillé dessus
a donné toutes les vraies informations
emplacement de l'élément de commande
et ce cours regorge de trouvailles
[musique]
ce complexe peut être comparé à l'espace
station gémissant la différence qui n'est pas
en orbite terrestre et en Arctique
[musique]
marine des états-unis
Amérique, l'OTAN a commencé à pratiquer et
jouer régulièrement des singles et
campagnes de groupe de surface de combat
navires
que je déclare pratiquement ce n'est pas
depuis le temps
militaire après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
[musique]
[applaudissements]